now the again the seven Habits of Highly
Effective People and how it applies to
language learning and the sixth habit
that Covey has is to synergize and he
talks about combining the strengths of
people through positive teamwork so as
to achieve goals that you couldn't
achieve on your own as I said in my
introductory video in language learning
the synergy comes from doing all of the
different skills or all of the different
language tasks there's no point in
saying that you know I can speak but I
can't read or I can read but I can't
speak and and everything that we do
contributes to the other skill reading
for example is not just about reading
although it's a wonderful way to learn
about a culture it's a wonderful way to
accumulate words if you accumulate words
you have more confidence when you're
speaking when we read we often sub
vocalize and so that reading is a way
you know to improve our pronunciation
because as we sub vocalize we become
aware that there are words that we don't
know how to pronounce and so we might
become more attentive and listen more
carefully for those words
when we're listening I find that that
for example if I listen without having
the text I have trouble remembering the
word I really need to read and then I
can associate a written depending on the
language it could be you know characters
in Chinese it could be simply an
alphabet in Russian or Korean but that I
associate this sound with these words
and that reinforces my ability to
remember it writing if you have the
discipline to do it is a great way to
get started in output because there's no
pressure on you so you're right and when
you write I find that when I write in a
foreign language basically I just write
as if I were speaking I don't you know
in English I can have a sort of a
literary style and a more casual style
but when I'm speaking a foreign language
unless is maybe French you know I don't
really have a separate literary style
it's essentially my spoken language
down so writing reinforces your speaking
ability in my opinion your speaking
ability reinforces your writing ability
so it's a good idea to practice all
skills even though as you know from my
videos I prefer to spend the the bulk of
my time on input for the longest while
to build up my sort of potential
capability and then I need more and more
opportunity to speak where I take
advantage of what I have built up
through these other activities but all
activities in fact work with each other
so you do have lots of synergy when you
are learning languages